hello gigi hello not even gonna lie
fangirl moment so i'm like really trying
to gather myself
fangirl moment yes what's going on girl
what you going through right now
we're meeting with you yes yes
stop this oh my goodness what
okay okay
oh you are so sweet listen
middle school oh you you were everything
for me oh gg thank you the first
question i have to ask you is
how are you doing in 2021 because it's
been a tough year
2020. it was um
not even gonna lie but i will say
that i appreciated 2020 for
all of the good that came out of it i
definitely
got closer with my my circle of friends
my village is what i call them my
friends and family and we were able to
you know stop and check in and really
you know dig deep in in things and
subjects that we
may have just slept under the rug if we
were busy you know
moving around congratulations on the
salt and pepper
lifetime biopic yes okay you're
fantastic in this
okay by the way thank you
what was your relationship with salt and
pepper growing up
so my relationship with them didn't
form until i was watching music videos
with my older brother that's what they
would do
so i was introduced by way of them
um and then once i got older of course
you know
it's like when you get older and you
know you've heard certain things but you
can't
pinpoint exactly where it was that's
what it was for me it was like i know i
know push it
it's like you come out the womb singing
push it or singing what a man
and then you know you go back to really
you know find out oh that was in vogue
on what a man and
you know then you start playing the
pieces together but but growing up with
older brothers
you know of course i knew the songs and
i knew the lyrics
but to put the faces to the names took
me getting older to do that
yep um i know that you're playing salt
in this
like what kind of research did you do to
play this character
so in the beginning when i first
initially got the audition it was
trying to find archived interviews
watching music videos and it was
it i'm not even going to hold you it was
kind of hard
finding all of this information because
there wasn't a whole lot of it you know
in order for things to be on youtube
someone has to publish it you know it
just doesn't pop out of thin
air um so the interviews and digging
things up were you know
it was kind of scarce but obviously i
did enough
to book the role and then after booking
yeah you know cheryl was an open book
you know so anything that i wanted to
know any question that i had
you know i i had the source you know she
was the bible
so my my research wasn't hard anymore
because now i had you know her to ask
all my questions too
oh my god you got to ask her the
questions
yeah what was that like that had to have
been so cool
i wish i could have seen it no it was it
was really great our first conversation
it was probably a week after i booked
and it was like a two and a half hour
conversation and
the first thing that she she actually
was like you know what do you want to
know
and i was like i just want to hear you
talk
so you know she just she just laid out a
lot of stuff
um and she was open and honest
from the very beginning it wasn't like a
buildup
of you know why i have to see how much
i'm gonna tell her
or let her in she let me in from the
very beginning
so it was a transparent relationship
from day one
and then when we got the script it was
okay now we're breaking down the script
we're going
scene by scene line by line you know i
wouldn't say this
say it this way okay we're going through
this scene and this is where the scene
ends
on the movie but now let's talk about
what happened in real life
yeah you know so it was amazing that she
shared
those experiences with me because she
didn't have to she could have said okay
well this is the end of the scene
for the movie and we're ending there but
she trusts me enough to tell me
the the real and what happened
after you know the cameras cut basically
so
that was that was an experience for me
and we got to a point where
we're not only talking about the movie
but we're talking about life experiences
things that don't have anything to do
with the movie things that i was going
through at the time you know and and
her even now to this day calling and
checking in
like you know hey baby girl what's going
on are you are you good you know
that type of you know relationship
that's what we build and i'm just
blessed to
to be able to have maintained that
relationship
you know because i feel like most people
assume after it's all
said and done you know we we walk away
and we you know
have our own lives but the fact that
she's still a part of my life and she
was able to meet my mom
and that was a cool experience for me
too so
yeah well how did your mom well your mom
must be just over the moon when you
booked this
and then that moment so tell us about
that yes
so they actually have a mutual friend um
so one of my mom's um really good
friends a
best friend of hers uh knows and met
cheryl
on some business and then there was a
collective zoom
that everybody was on so they were able
to meet and
and talk about me and you know share a
moment
so that was that was really really nice
did you feel
pressure to play her not just because
she is so incredibly iconic but given
the amount of information
how much she let you in did you feel
like oh god i really
i hope i nailed this did you have that
sense
i did in the very beginning yeah so
through the audition process i was not
aware
that she was watching me essentially
um so then after booking because you
know i went into it after i got it i was
like
okay so now i have to call her she's
expecting my call
but it's like a blind date that's what
my thought process was
like she doesn't know who i am yeah um
but then after learning you know
she had to sign off on me she was
watching
the process so she knew me
you know um then then the pressure went
away
and because to she wasn't she wasn't
hard to talk to she wasn't hard to
you know relate to the fact that she
opened her heart and her story to me so
that
that was comforting having her on set
and just being able to like peek around
like
is that are we good you know there was
one scene
um one of my purging scenes she was
there on set
and i was crying carrying on ugly cry
too um but once it was done
i couldn't stop crying and on the other
side in video village she was crying
and then she came into the bathroom once
everybody cleared out
and you know we just hugged and she was
like i'm i'm here
i'll stay in here for as long as you
need you know just get it out
i was a mess like i don't know
what in me wouldn't let me stop crying
but like she she stopped
everything for me to have my moment yeah
so
that was that's that's a story from said
that i will
definitely cherish for sure salt and
pepper as executive producers on this
and i know that you got mentoring which
is incredible but
was there anything specific that just
hands-on advice that you got
that just meant the world to you or
really helped you out
um i would say just
cheryl reiterating things like
staying true to yourself and
you know not not staying
in situations that don't serve you
because that was you know another
off movie topic we were talking about
but that's still tied into
you know what we were doing um but just
just
things like that just her sharing
her story and experiences and and the
essence and the things that she learned
yeah and me taking that on and
even applying it in my everyday life
you know like sometimes i would have to
stop and say okay well what chair will
do
oh because yeah yeah and i told her even
with
some of the some of the stories that she
shared i'm like
yeah i got the cops called on me you're
so much better than me
so yeah definitely took me through a lot
of like
hey g maybe you should chill or
apply some of the things that cheryl you
know
shared with you or you know maintain
your chill and you're cool be
cheryl-like
and then certain experiences so yeah i
definitely take all of that
and i constantly remind her and tell her
you know how appreciative i am of her
and how i just love her so much for
trusting me
with such a huge responsibility and
you know the fact that at the end of the
day
she was proud of me and proud of what i
did and i even had a conversation with
corinne her daughter
she had pulled me aside one day um when
karen was on set and she was like i just
want to thank you
like you know my mom was nervous about
all of this but the fact that you're
approaching it with
the utmost respect and you know how much
dedication you're putting into it you
know i i just want to thank you
from me and from her and the fact that
she was even having that conversation
with corinne too
about you know the work that i put into
it was
was definitely just a it was
it was an amazing thing to hear to know
that i was on the right track
and you know honoring her and you know
her legacy for sure
yeah that's got to be such a relief oh
you know like thank the lord happy
you're happy
i'm i'm happy you're happy in the spirit
of
black history month and celebrating
black excellence i think this question
is is perfect for this
and if you can kind of um say what
how we can celebrate them so for example
um
what salt and pepper did in the music
industry
is so incredibly iconic what they did
for the culture what they did for the
community is so incredible
just what they mean to you and what you
think they mean to
a lot of us hip-hop royalty
at the end of the day women pioneers
you know they they just dug you fresh
you feel me like that was their first
track they went to dougie fresh's high
school
yeah and dissed him on his own turf you
know up on the lunch tables and we do do
that in the movies so you'll see that
um but not backing down
you know like they didn't
say oh we're going to be rappers they
were going to school to be nurses
they fell into this and yet they
killed it they they still used their
platform
for awareness you know me like
they use their influence and their
platform for
the betterment of the world and their
people
you know so and and for women you know
to show women that
they can do anything that a man does
you